[Music]
IBM messaging continues to be the proven
market leading messaging solution used
by thousands of customers across the
globe eighty-five percent of Fortune 100
companies and 94% of the world's top 100
banks use IBM messaging as their trusted
messaging background this year we're
celebrating 25 years of IBM messaging
development we've always been at the
forefront working closely with our
customers and continually evolving our
offerings
we're still leading the way setting the
standard for secure reliable enterprise
grade messaging developed by a dedicated
messaging team in Hursley IBM's largest
European development innovation has
always been a hallmark of IBM messaging
when we now support more industries and
technologies than ever before so whether
you need to harness the full potential
of the Internet of Things will
incorporate cognitive capabilities
will integrate with IBM objects IBM
messaging hasn't come
[Music]
in an ever-changing world you can be
confident idea messaging will continue
to lead the way
IBM messaging
25 years ago
[Music]
you